everybody welcome to live coding with
Jesse I'm Jesse today we're going to
work with a tool that I've never worked
with before and we're gonna do some
database stuff which is not really
common for us on this stream usually we
handle front-end work but Microsoft has
come out with and I don't know when this
came out but I just found out about it
yesterday sequel
operation studio and when when we see it
in a minute you'll see it looks a lot
like Visual Studio code it's an electron
app which is cool to look at another
electron app since we started building
one yesterday but I finally got access
to a database so if you've been watching
for a while you know I've been talking
about this for at least a few weeks now
probably longer and so I had some some
of the people over a nighty made a copy
of the database that the main site for
for this university runs on so
Franciscan ddu which runs on a really
old content management system that we
want to migrate away from but we want to
try to get the data out of that database
and put it in another database in a
format that will be better for whatever
CMS we decide to use most likely
WordPress but I'm still open to other
options so I'll give you we're gonna
look at a database in just a minute but
so far I think it's good but I'd like
you all to you know check it out as well
and then we're going to decide what the
best way to transfer this this is and
then maybe we'll you know we'll try to
do some some tests to see you know what
would work I also have a lot of updates
that need to be done for our project one
or catechetical Institute site and I'll
talk about that at the
the stream when we do the
question-and-answer portion so I had a
meeting yesterday afternoon about that
which is why I didn't stream and I'll
probably be making all of those into
issues on the github repo but I'd like
to kind of talk through him first in
today's stream at the end all right so
let's let me switch my view here all
right so this is this is it this is the
I keep forgetting the name of it it's
Microsoft's sequels studio no sequel
operation studio yeah yeah that's it
yep all right so basically let's see is
that big enough let me know if it's not
big enough I could make it bigger so it
I don't know how many of you work with
databases but this this query gets
everything from from content right so we
have a table called content we actually
have quite a few tables here content
will be the most important that's where
we get the majority of all the data so
you see right now we every piece of
content has an ID but what I'm really
worried about here is the content title
and then the content HTML so this is
good news that I think pretty much all
the content on the site has this this
title and content HTML we can grab that
that's that's all we need really we
don't really need to keep the IDS the
only other piece of data that's going to
be useful is the content there's a
content type which I can't find now but
somewhere in here it's a content type
now it's just they're just numbers so
content type one two three
so I need to figure out what those
numbers correspond to but this should
help us because the different content
types will probably end up being
different custom post types and on our
new CMS so we need to make sure we bring
them in as that so we're not just going
to bring all this in and have it be one
giant table like it is now but it
depends it really depends on the format
that we need for our new CMS but this is
good news so far let me pull this up we
can see more of it at a time and I'll
bring that down so there's a couple
things that I think we really need to
get out of the way just right off the
bat number one we got to change this
color theme right we can't have this
this bright white stuff so let's say
let's try what do we see this one looks
good
Monica or we could do default dark that
looks nice we'll go with default dark
now I'm not sure if we can get a package
for this and bring in a new theme Oh
actually it's letting us bring in the
seti icon thing very cool
alright so now that we have the
background color set now we can really
get started so
all right so I guess first off what I
want to do is open it up to anybody out
there that has experience with databases
if you have any ideas to throw out let
me know I'm going to throw out a few my
ideas to what I think the best course of
action will be and let's try to decide
on one and and maybe try something out
in today's stream so I don't really have
that much of a goal other than just
testing some things out I've never done
this before so I don't really know what
to expect in terms of difficulty and in
time so if you have an idea go ahead and
throw it in a live chat I'll check back
in there in a minute or so
otherwise let me share with you some of
my thoughts so let's see I'm thinking
what we potentially could do is just
export a lot of this data how you know
whatever format that we would like and
then pull that data in basically to
wherever so one of the difficulties here
I guess I should mention this I can only
log in to this database from this
computer on this network so I believe
that I am granted access based on my IP
address I'll have to verify that with
the people over in IT but when I was
trying to log on yesterday and then
earlier today someone from IT had to
come over and it was a lot of
troubleshooting to try to get give me
access to this so I have to be on a
certain network here on campus so that's
gonna limit us right so we couldn't just
you know pool data you know somewhere
else right it has to be here on this
computer so that may or may not be an
issue but what I'm what I'm thinking and
maybe
is already like a sequel way of doing
this I assume there might be but in
terms of what I'm familiar with we can
potentially pull this data out and then
get rid of all the all the data that we
don't need so that's going to include a
lot of these a lot of these columns that
we just won't need at all but then also
some of this data we don't need to
transfer over so some of this stuff
isn't even live on the site anymore it's
obviously still here but it's marked I
believe one of these columns will say
whether or not something is actually
live so we need to get rid of all those
as well and at that point once we get it
narrowed down to what we want then then
we could see about transferring that so
here's my basic probably don't have to
look anything up way of doing this let
me know if it's ridiculous so we we
could potentially and I think this
sounds kind of silly but I'm pretty sure
it'll work we could potentially just
export this in Excel or as a CSV or JSON
right but if we did that will you just
go in delete rows and we'd have all that
data there in a format that wouldn't be
too difficult to pull out and put pretty
much anywhere we wanted okay so that's
my option
I guess the benefit of that would be we
we could very easily get a good idea of
just how much of this we actually need
we could do some filtering which could
be useful just to see now umberto in the
live chat has some ideas as well so
Umberto says if we use sequel server
in studio we can generate the sequel
scripts for create table insert
statements logins users etc this is
let's see that might cause issues with
the column with the HTML wondering all
right so I'm gonna ask you all if
somebody has okay so the exporting to
CSV or Excel imperative saying it might
it might cause some issues all right
good to know so let's go on to plan B
right Nicola says what happened to
electron I'm really excited project six
Nikolas will be going back to project
six we're gonna be jumping around a bit
so Oh project six will receive updates
periodically and we'll keep checking in
on it and we will do some streams that
will be dedicated entirely to it but I
don't really have a timeline for though
that needs to be done so I guess you
know you can always check in and you
know when you get to notification if
you're subscribed to the channel you get
the notification of the title check if
it's project six if you're really only
interested in that then you check that
out otherwise you know then you could
skip the other stuff I guess let's see
okay so here's my other idea we could
let's see how we do this so for this
database it's a copy
but I only have read access I can't
change anything within this database but
what we could do I suppose is create
another database and we can even use
this tool oh it's a sequel operation
studio we can even use this tool to
start to create some you know
some tables and things and pull some of
this stuff over what I'm not sure about
is you know could we pull things
directly from here and then insert them
in another table you know all within
sequel operation studio so as I
mentioned earlier I just started using
this this morning I downloaded yesterday
couldn't connect to the database and so
I didn't really get a chance to use it
till this morning so that's something
that I'm not sure if that would work but
if it did work that would be great I
guess that's worth a shot because the
next step would be I don't even know the
next step I guess would be let's just
try to pull this data out put it
somewhere else where we have read and
write access maybe we can manipulate it
I guess if we even just pulled it out
somewhere that would be more accessible
so I didn't have to be here on my
machine that might be useful we could
try to create some sort of API to get
info if we wanted to because to be
honest with you I'm not really that
familiar with the sequel queries but if
we could make a really basic API to do
things and then we could use JavaScript
to do a lot so anyway let's just let's
just mess around a little bit and try
some things so we're gonna create
I know that there's a way to create a
database actually you know what are we
still that may not work I'm not exactly
sure if I'm still connected to this
server I suppose I have to do everything
on this server hmm okay well let's pull
I just want to go through this and see
what we're dealing with in terms of how
ridiculously long this would be
okay so obviously this is super long
there's definitely going to be some
editing that needs to take place here as
I'm looking at some of this HTML there's
a lot of extra stuff in here that we're
not going to use that's unfortunate but
at least we can get some of the data
okay
hey John John Hanson just came in a live
shot how's it going
all right so let's
you know what let's let's go back here
and let's run a different query because
I definitely don't want to bother
bringing in anything that's not
currently live on the site so let's
check out our our headings here
this content status
I'm not sure what these stand for on the
database
okay so we do have published which I'm
assuming zero is not published and one
is published so we can rule out anything
I guess that's not published
okay cool so that my uncle Pat is in the
live chat and he said active is in act
active and inactive is for the status so
awesome that makes a lot of sense
thank you okay cool so the I'm then
assuming we don't need to bother with
the inactive yeah I'm not even sure why
these are in here they sound like a blog
post we don't even host the blogs here
any in this system
and a lot of these Wow check out the
dates on some of these when we were
talking events from 2015 yeah we
definitely don't need a lot of this
stuff all right here's what I'm gonna do
- right now this will help us up not
right now but later on and this will be
fun a hub let me say this I'm gonna say
this as an excel file it's gonna be
insane and huge but I'm not gonna open
it I'm gonna send it to my boss so
because my boss is in charge of all this
content and he's been here since before
this site was even developed at all so
he's overseeing everything that's gone
into here so he'll be able to tell much
more quickly than I can what what
content in here is should be kept and
which should not be kept so I will I'll
you know I'm not gonna send it to him
right now cuz that's not really gonna be
fun on the stream but then that way he
can take a look at some of it maybe even
tell me you know hopefully there's some
identifiers in here that would help us
out at the very least I suppose he may
be able to say you know any you know any
content types that are content type 3
both that were put in there before a
certain date we can get rid of that
would be helpful
John Hanson says who would and how would
that HTML be imputed such generated and
we're from WordPress we're going to
probably WordPress but yes so this data
will be put in to a different database
and then yeah the content would then be
could be editable through that CMS but
we're still going to use the API to
bring it in and pull them into our react
site yeah so the Excel trying to open
this in Excel has not crashed my
computer yet but it is taking forever
it's letting me do other stuff while I'm
waiting on that so I was just late on
that over here on the side I'm home both
in with it anymore I look at it after
the stream all right so I'm barrister
saying we could try to create database
it'll basically let's see
create
create database and I don't know let's
just call this
no I was schoolin connection
all right so it's asking me to put in a
different address so I just want to go
into here let's see what happened no
does the password not in shoot I didn't
hit remember password um what was the
password I think that was it let me get
remember this time so I'm gonna have to
remember it again
No
yeah
all right that's kids so that is not
know everything right now so for some
reason I still have this in here which
I'm not gonna mess with this now I'll be
assuming that you know maybe I'm not
connected really but it's just still
showing me this because I I did the
query when I was still connected so I am
getting the login that I used for this
was not the login that I will get
hopefully soon so if I can remember this
password I'm not worried about it
because I should be getting a new one
soon Mac I guess I could just open up
the help page
which the results found for create
database he started attacking taste
all right so we have Umberto asked if
we'll be sticking with Microsoft sequel
server for your database no I will not
be sticking with that for my database so
I guess we it doesn't really matter we
shouldn't create it through here anyway
also since you might not have grant
permission for create database yeah I
don't think I can I can change or do
anything I think I can just read data
okay so I'm fair to saying the other
option I use in Devi's local DB but I'm
on Windows I don't know if that works
for Mac doubt it does okay let's
all right so let's let us think about
this then for sure if we're gonna go
with WordPress my sequel will be the
database that we go with if we go with a
different system I have no idea what
we'll be using so should we just try to
do something then with my sequel that
might be the best bet right now I guess
that's kind of the only the only thing
that we would kind of know about for
sure that we want to use
all right so let's see if we can just
get a local my sequel database going
hmm
all right it looks like can you not do
this on a Mac does anybody installed my
sequel on a Mac because there are no
instructions for that I'm seeing on the
know what the Oracle website
I guess we could just create a droplet
on digitalocean
all right let's see if we can just
create
yeah I said we could we could just
create really quickly a wordpress
installation I mean maybe maybe that
would just kind of really easily show us
what like what would happen if we
imported things in a certain way
let's see
all right let's let's do that so let me
show you show this so this is assuming
that we're gonna go with WordPress this
is the structure that we need so if we
install WordPress first and we'll just
do we're not going to go through the
whole installation process that you'll
be done before we'll just do the
digitalocean one-click install and we'll
just spin up the droplet just to test
we'll do a really basic droplet and then
we'll just get rid of it when we don't
need it anymore but the only thing that
we really need to worry about changing
right now is this WP posts
so actually a lot of these fields match
up pretty well with what we already have
okay
all right I think that'll work
all right
I'll bring this over so we can see so
it's just digitalocean I'm just gonna go
with this WordPress one-click install we
can't do a $5 droplet if if you do the
install you know if you start out just
with like a Linux distro and do it
install WordPress on your own you can
actually get away with running it on the
$5 an hour droplet which is nice and it
actually works it it'll run everything I
have WordPress sites I'm just using the
headless WordPress installs on $5
droplets that have been running for
months and months and have been doing
fine but for for now just for speed will
will be alright with the 10 I don't
think we really don't need anything
special just for testing so yeah let's
monitor at least droplet
okay the PDB toes I works right yeah
that looks good
alright let's create that oh cool so
Michael is is here and Michael knows
sequel or SQL actually let me know in a
live chat what do you prefer to say or
what do you think is the correct way to
say it's sequel or SQL I I think sequel
is easier to say and so I go with that
but I do hear a lot of people saying SQL
alright so this is almost done great we
should be able think we should be able
to go here gosh
this IP probably won't do anything
I wonder if you can do okay so I have to
SSH in enable my WordPress installation
okay not a problem let's copy that and
we've got the terminal open already let
me make this bigger so y'all can see and
I know I have completely forgotten about
the Pomodoro timer for this one but
there's not a whole lot going on the
live chat so I'm just gonna not do that
for now if I notice a lot of activity
then maybe we'll go back to it but I've
been able to keep up with with the chat
as we're going so if I can keep doing
that we should be alright okay got some
some votes here for for sequel all right
cool
also then Angie sorry if I mispronounced
that says what happened is setting up an
electron project we're going to go back
with to the electron project so we're
gonna kind of bounce around between
projects but we will go back to the
electron project at some point the repo
and github is there so feel free to
check out what we have so far it's it's
set up pretty nicely so it can certainly
be forked at this point clone you could
you know work on it for your own
projects or contribute if you'd like but
we'll get back to it
John Hanson's asking about why the
Microsoft sequel over my sequel and
isn't my sequel easy yeah we're so what
we're gonna do is take that data out of
that sequel server database and we're
gonna put it in to the my sequel that's
running with our WordPress install so we
are moving away from that from that
Microsoft server okay I think this
should get us in yep
all right cool we are in and worship as
been enabled wonderful
all right so hopefully I can get into
this WordPress install just with an IP
address if not it wouldn't be a problem
to make a sub domain you know quickly
okay so it looks like I can use the IP
so let's try that out
it's the same yeah I was the same okay
cool
you should
sorry I can't show you the password
let's go let me move this over and then
do the password so I'll change what was
there and copy so wonderful
I have to put in I think sometimes for
my work email these these emails from
WordPress get blocked so I'm putting in
my my personal email for that okay
this log in London says can you give me
hints on this question yeah sure what is
your question alright awesome so we have
a wordpress install we may as well just
to update this now before we do anything
I hate to actually do something and then
update and have it mess up what we've
done so if you've never used WordPress
before this is what the admin panel
looks like WordPress updates are super
fast and easy you see that it's already
done
I couldn't even say little WordPress
update was and before it finished so you
hit the update normally it's a good idea
to back up a site first but since we
have nothing in this site we didn't need
to and now it tells us all about you
know what happened when we update it we
can also go down here check out our
plugins this can be updated now we're
not even using it right now but just to
show you how easy it is to update that
plug-in literally a few seconds so what
we'll do now is we'll go to I guess
we'll go in
through here I'm gonna get in oh sorry
so here's my idea
WordPress already comes with its
WordPress API should we or could we use
the API to put the data into the
database instead of directly
manipulating the database let me know
what you all think so if we were to
directly manipulate the database I would
need to I guess be able to open up some
type of tool to where I could read that
database because doing it all from the
terminal I think would be somewhat more
difficult but at least if we use the API
it should put the data in properly so I
guess and I could try it yeah let's try
it
it's a problem with the wordpress api is
you really have to make sure you get a
new tutorial or even make sure you're on
the right set of documentation because
it's changed so much since it you know
they first we're working on it
there you go this one looks pretty new
so hopefully this will work let me bring
you sober on the other screen so y'all
can see what I'm doing
Nick s why am I not using sequel server
management probably because I'm not
exactly sure what that is so if I should
be using it let me know you send me a
link or point me in the right direction
I'll check it out I'm not I I guess I
didn't say this yet I'm really really
inexperienced when it comes to database
stuff so that's why I'm kind of relying
on on help from you all so I know
there's some of you that have a lot more
experience with databases so if you came
here to learn a lot from me you will be
disappointed but the other people that
are watching the stream and talking in a
live chat will probably be able to teach
me and everyone else a lot so I'm gonna
do my best to take their advice and read
that out and then try to act on that and
I'm gonna keep an eye on the clock just
to make sure all right so we haven't
been going for an hour yet so this is
not too bad let's see I want to be a
reference let's go to our posts
all right
well let's first create a post here's
what we want okay we're gonna create a
post do we need um I suppose we need all
of these I guess they don't need to be
no there's no way we need all of it
because some of these can certainly be
blank and they'll still be a post so
let's all right so we need to send a
post request to this endpoint with this
data all right not too bad
I see here's what I'm thinking
let me let me check in the live chat for
a second here to see if someone else has
a better idea before I share what I'm
about to do Lennon as a question about
specifying how fonts should degrade you
should be able to just put font family
and then whatever font you want to
display first will be first and then put
a comma and then put in the next font in
a comma in the next font so it could be
something like the first one would be
Roboto you would you need to put that I
don't you wouldn't need to put Roboto in
quotes it's just one word
so it'd be font family colon space
Roboto assuming you've already brought
in that font and then comma space
sans-serif comma space I don't know
whatever I see you probably sans-serif
would be your second one if you wanted
something else to fall back on in
between there you certainly could put
that in there but that's generally how
you do it and that's with CSS so if you
know you put that on you know whatever
you know selector that that you want for
those falsity grades so anyway Lenin let
me know if you need more info or
something like that I can certainly
address it again later on in the stream
or you know send me a message on Twitter
you know show me a little bit of what
you have that you're working with and
maybe I can help you you know more
specifically
let's see
so take a look on yulian says take a
look on dr. and dr. Campos save you $10
on droplet and run everything locally
you know what docker is a good idea
probably maybe we at some point should
end up doing things with docker I'm just
gonna keep going with what I'm doing
right now just to save time but I think
that is actually a great idea to use
docker for something like this if you
don't know what docker is it's a way to
set up I guess you maybe call it
something like a virtual server that can
run on your machine it can be copied and
so basically you have this identical
environment anywhere you put that that
docker container so on the server on
your local machine on someone else's
local machine no matter what whether
you're running Linux Mac Windows no
matter what type of server you would
have an identical environment within
that container so it's really cool but I
don't I really don't want to try to set
it up here during the stream at least
not during this stream maybe in a future
one okay Joan Boyce is out of the
interested in seeing how to use an API
to import data into a new database okay
so that's basically my idea now so we
did we X we did export the data so let's
do this
so we exported that data where's it up
over here and let's go over yeah so
we've exported all our data into this
gigantic JSON file so what I was
thinking was
let's do
[Music]
so I lost my train of thought I was
reading something in the live chat
apologies that Glenn says hello from
Spain hey how's it going thanks for
joining us John Hanson says in order to
have consistent HTML content do you have
to keep the Styles simplified would it
not be best to build a template in
WordPress that all users need to use to
submit with yeah it'll be well I mean
will you'll see what do we get to that
part it'll be similar the way we've done
things with pulling data from the
WordPress API and that will give users
field certain fields to fill out with
like validation on those fields so they
will only be able to put in certain
things that you want them to put in and
they'll probably it'll most likely be
some sort of approval process as well so
we'll have you know student workers
doing this but unless they're
experienced they won't just be able to
you know directly publish anything so
there'll be some checks on what you know
what kind of goes through there all
right so here's what I'm thinking we
create a and I'll probably do this I
suppose a node because that's what I
wear I would know how to do this with
let me know if there's a better way to
do this if we could do it like you know
straight from the command line or like a
bad script or something maybe that'll be
faster but what we would what we would
do is we would grab all the so I think I
just went off camera so lean back well
we would grab just like we were hitting
an API endpoint right we would grab data
from this JSON file pull it in we'd
iterate over that and each time we'd
iterate over that we would call this API
endpoint and we would post it because
I'm it I don't know if
there's a way to bulk do post yeah so
unless we find some way to do bulk
edition of post with the API we will
have to do it one by one but it would
enter way through that and then using
this it would send a post request to our
site so that's how the flow of data
would go from sequel server to JSON pull
the JSON into node send it as a post
request to the WordPress API and then
the WordPress API would insert that into
a my sequel database underneath the WP
post table the nice thing that I like
about this is that potentially like
we're going to have differences between
the the fields that we have here and
what we have in our other the other
database so for instance you know when
we have you not all these match up
properly I don't even know if these
dates are in the right format right but
what we could do is when we do that
iteration every time you pull in data
from the JSON file we can have you know
some mutations of the data going on so
we could have something that like and
this is a prime example or call them
where it has content type which I can't
find right now here we go content type I
don't want the post type to be one in
WordPress right it needs to be a string
a name of that post type so we could
have something you know that would check
if content type is one then make the
field post type I'm assuming there's a
field called posts type in here
somewhere I don't know what to find it
we do have to find it or we may have to
modify the API
yeah we may have to modify the API not a
problem we don't need to do that right
now so what we either do is download a
ready-made plugin that can handle that
or we can just write a plug-in ourselves
probably depends on I don't know does
anybody really want to go through
writing a PHP plugin not today but in
the future a future stream let me know
I'll think about it
maybe we'll do that anyway it would
change that data so anytime let's say
the put content type was one instead it
would make the the post type for
WordPress I don't know let's say faculty
members right because we would have a
post type for faculty members we could
display their BIOS and stuff on on the
page so right does that make sense I
don't know let me know if it doesn't
make any sense at all it'll probably
make sense once we do it so let's think
should we run this I suppose we could
run this right on our local machine
right is there any reason why we
couldn't we have node on this machine we
could most certainly make a note a
JavaScript file run it in node and it
could handle all that the only thing I'm
worried about slightly is I mean let's
say we add like 9,000 posts can the
wordpress api handle that much all at
once especially on a ten-dollar droplet
I don't know we could maybe set a
timeout and just let it go for a long
time I'm sorry you know what I mean like
an interval right so it would only try
to send a post I don't know
ten seconds or something right that
should be enough time all right so let
me catch up here on the live chat
quickly and make sure I'm on the right
track here okay so Nick has clarified a
sequel server management studio is an
integrated environment for managing any
sequel infrastructure you can use it to
access configure manage administer and
develop all components of sequel server
ok that's cool
I may look into that then at some point
maybe after the stream today or sometime
tomorrow if I can okay Umberto's says it
sounds pretty easy to use the API since
we already have the JSON file yeah as
soon as I saw that I can export it to
JSON and one-click that was immediately
what I thought about was so she's the
API ok Nyx's but if you're focused on T
sequel Microsoft sequel operation studio
is better for some good code snippets
customizable server and database
dashboards ok
eine ein mission says what are you using
to call and store in the database this
so this is what I'm using I assume this
is what you're asking about correct me
if I'm wrong this is Microsoft's sequel
operation studio and I just found out
about it yesterday but it's an electron
app so it runs as a desktop app and I
like it so far I don't really have much
to compare it to the only other thing we
even remotely like this that I've used
is what it like PHP myadmin
or whatever it's called and so far I
like this a lot better
okay so post types is on the left column
okay cool thank you
Daniel noticed post types on the left
column here interesting so you can't for
requests and we get them list types
retrieve it hmm oh you know what here's
what I think we can do I'm not a hundred
percent sure that we could do this by
default we still may need a plug-in but
potentially we could as long as we
create the post type yeah we should be
able to do this so I don't know how many
of you were watched the last time we
created a custom WordPress plug-in but
we with that plug-in we created custom
post types and then we enable them to
use the WordPress API and that's how we
got data from them I'm assuming that if
we enable the API we enable all of it so
we can also pass data in so what we
would end up doing is resume then
instead of for those types that aren't
posts which most of them won't actually
be post because we're not even going to
have a blog on the site there'll be
something else
so it would be WP v2 and then here we
would say right and that would be the
name of the type so it wouldn't be posts
and then a type over here it would be an
entirely different word right here so
I'm I'm almost positive that that will
work and great great and so Daniel thank
you so much for mentioning that because
now once I saw it it all came back to me
it has been a little while since we
worked with the WordPress API see
Umberto's says it the alternative I'm
paraphrasing some hope you don't mind
Umberto see the alternative to doing it
through the API like I just described
would be generating
the table and inserting data scripts and
then potentially modifying the file to
match the my sequel syntax so Alberto
yet for me trying to think about doing
that I have no idea and I have to look
up every step of the way but I am very
familiar with the WordPress API so even
if the WordPress API wouldn't be the
ideal way to do it for our purposes
right now and for my capabilities it's
probably going to end up being the
shortest way to do it let's see my class
if all the data was in that one table
yeah pretty much
yep so this table as a lot of rows I
don't want to if this number down here
is the correct numbers nine thousand six
hundred and eighty-three rows so this is
it the content table I mean as it seems
has all the content for the site we can
check out some of the other tables as
well let's see oops there we go so there
are quite a lot of tables here so let's
just check it out quickly that way you
know some of you who maybe are more
familiar there we go
make it obscenely big for a minute to
see you all can see so a lot of these
tables I imagine are pretty much empty
because we don't actually use any of
those features on the on the site all
right so we have requests template we
don't have to worry about any of the
template stuff because that's not being
carried over any user stuff we don't
have to worry about most a lot of the
users aren't even working here anymore
because they're student workers and
they've graduated
[Music]
simile like approval things it's I don't
think we'll worry about assets offense I
might have to check out this content
events because we have you some of their
event things but the thing with the
events is once the event happens it
expires and we don't really need it
anymore
so we may not even bother pulling in
events cuz we don't really need the old
events why I think that back we might
just export the the JSON for the events
but while they're putting it in the
WordPress installation because we won't
need him it might be nice to have them
all right go so Maya the the accountant
here that's Franciscan University of
student oh they just came in to live
chat I'm pretty sure that's Brian who
works here with me is a full-stack
developer so Brian says the he knows a
lot more about the content than I do so
it seems that we don't need to worry
about the events rook asks how big the
entire database is I don't really know
but the database guy from IT who's a
really nice guy and came over and helped
me this morning he said that the 80% of
the size of the database is in the the
versions so like the archive which i
think is it saves a history of all the
changes which we all need any of that so
we could we don't have to worry about
eighty percent of the stuff in here for
sure and then of the twenty percent
that's left over most of it is in this
content table here so like I said the
content table is really the vast
majority of all we need to
worried about the calendar I don't think
we have we use the calendar we only use
member subscriptions yeah this kind of
thing device configuration stuff we
won't need I don't know that we use the
categories extensively enough they'll
change we don't need that this is the
content table that we have open right
now and so this is just some some stats
and things we don't need any of that is
it content history maybe it's content
history that's that's quite large as
well so coupon currency customers we
don't do any e-commerce yeah I think we
are we're not gonna need these
most of these sorry I'm scrolling
through pretty quickly I'm not sure if
y'all can even see I'll definitely run
this by I'll have Brian take a look at
it since he knows more about the site
and probably my boss as well just to
scan through and see if there's anything
else that looks like it might be
something we need but it does not look
like it's okay
I on mission says is your data store in
WordPress and that's why you need to use
the WordPress API now I want to put it
into WordPress so that's why we're using
the WordPress API Michael has is it an
archive or a backup yeah it's it's a
copy of the current database that's in
use with you know we just have read-only
access to it
Dania says not like 8 gigabytes in a
comments table so you're good yeah we
don't have comments enabled anywhere so
we don't have to worry about it okay all
right so I think we're good
Michael asks how often do you do the
backup I have no idea because we don't
we don't handle the backups IT if there
are backups IT handles them so I don't
really know this backup was made very
recently I think within the last few
days okay let me check the time and then
see what we can accomplish okay let's
just take a look
[Music]
you know what we could maybe start to
write some of the node code but we can't
run it because I can't remember the
password that I used to log in here so
it's not it's not gonna work unless I
can remember this password it's possible
that it just wouldn't let me login
because I was trying to create something
so I guess we can make some of the yeah
we can do some of the code we can test
it out with the password as I think it
is and then if it doesn't work it
doesn't work we'll I'll wait till I get
my other account we'll go back to it see
my class I says are you hiring I have to
work remotely though unfortunately we're
not we don't hire remote workers if we
did I'd probably be sitting in my house
right now
but yeah if we ever I hope that we can
start to hire remote at some point at
least for developers and if we do start
that I will definitely let all of you
know in the stream Julian says I
recommend to look on the WPC oh I put
the content of each post into a file
then create posts from the content WP
pose create context as category
I do it in bulk okay that's X so that's
not a bad idea my question then would be
though assuming that we have to
manipulate some of the data and change
it would it be it I'm just at some point
we'll have to do that right so would it
make it easier to do it like that um
I'll have to look into it more I suppose
I think right now it is worth it to do
do a little bit of stuff in node just
right now just to get an idea of you
know is is this even possible
all right so let's go to one of our
editors here since we're dealing with
Microsoft stuff let's let's bring up
let's use Visual Studio code and I have
our electron project up but for now I'm
just going to open a new file and let's
pull in let's yeah let's save this and
in projects and let's call this do new
folder be migration create and then
within here we'll just call this migrate
j/s okay great what message am i getting
here whoa slide for single drops of
consolation globally okay I'm not really
worried about a yes lamp right now let's
see
Nik as does the database have any kind
of mapping tables I I don't really know
to be entirely honest I'm not even sure
what the mapping tables are my mission
says is it isn't it great that you can
broadcast at work how boring would it be
otherwise
yeah it does make things a little bit
more exciting when everybody can see me
mess up alright so actually let me take
I could probably pull some of our node
code that we've used earlier think we
used
now I'm thinking we need to import and
use I'd like to use note fetch to submit
being more complicated than I'd hoped
all right well I can at the very least
plan out what we're gonna do and then we
can go from there see if we can code
anything out so we need to
you should probably
okay so this is my basic plan
we'll get the data well frog we can run
a filter if we really wanted to which it
may end up being useful to just to run
the filter we could either filter here
or we could go over here and when we
actually do our query we could try to
only select things that we want we'll
get a much smaller file so I'm thinking
of things that you know inactive content
you know content that's expired or just
content that we have no intention to
bring over to the new site so however we
do it here or here whatever we want to
do we do need to filter out the stuff we
don't need no sense in making those
posts if we don't want them anymore and
then we'll go through make the changes
like we talked about so that the data is
in the correct format that we need to
send it so then we'll send that post
request and then the last part here I
think it would be a good idea obviously
to check for errors right will get a
message back saying whether or not we
succeeded in our request to to make a
new post so if it fails you know
possibly we would we could try again you
know wait a certain amount of time try
again and then you know if it fails
twice at that point we can just log love
the ID that way we can we have a record
then of you know what didn't go over I'm
hoping that the list of stuff that
didn't work will be small if it's a long
list that's going to be a pain
okay so embarrassed I was saying said I
think it's better to modify that in in
the node code so here with JavaScript
doing it in one place rather than fine
and replace in a text file that's cool I
agree and I'm much more comfortable
editing it you know through true note I
mean think about how many times we've
done the same thing you know in our
react components when we've made an API
call and change things in the data
before we rendered it right so this will
be very familiar to us make saying get
the data from the JSON with bulk and
open rows set all right Nick I'm
interested in hearing more about that
because I'm not exactly sure what what
the benefit is from that or anything but
if you could explain it a little bit
more to me since I'm my nose if this
kind of thing is very limited I would
appreciate it yeah ah Dan you says
unless you've got that client that says
I need everything yeah luckily my boss
is perfectly fine with getting rid of
all the stuff that we don't need like I
said I think it's worthwhile to save
everything in at the very least save it
in JSON format and then you know keep
backups of that so that at some point if
we ever really need to find a piece of
content it wouldn't be that hard to just
search for it I don't want to keep these
databases alive you know as is anywhere
because that takes up you know D this
website these databases are hosted
physically on campus by the IT
department so it would save them time
and money they'll be able to reuse those
servers for other things if we could
just completely get rid of it all so
that's the plan so any backups that we
want
I guess at first we could do a test yeah
let's do a test
all right let me see the time I'm gonna
bring you a note fetch because I like to
use fetch I'm not really interested in
doing it any other way
let's see
I guess I'll have to earn it this
project and with all right let's go
ahead in the console this is kind of why
I I'm wondering whether or not I should
I should do this there we go
there we go what if I could just take
yarn will it in it
all right there we go question name yeah
that's good that's good
she likes you but all this stuck it
doesn't even really matter
yeah
true right there we go okay so now let's
do yarn
add NPM I mean node okay wonderful
oops
let's go with
[Music]
let's pull in that that file and put it
in the right spot so right now we just
have that in documents and I want it in
a project so sorry this is really small
probably hard to see but let's just pull
this over it we call it results dot JSON
yes so let's pull that over and I'm not
even gonna make folders this is so this
is basic we don't even need folders for
this I am gonna make it lower case
because it bothers me there you go so we
have our results
great all right so
it's
Jason
good
either like look at example it's been so
long since I've actually wrote one of
these from scratch alright let's check
this out
trying to get the last project where we
did this
I think we've used this in pretty much
every project
yeah we've done this with the bulletin
the react version of the bulletin so
let's check that out
and we're we're using note fetch there
all right cool I'm gonna copy and paste
this over here we've got quite a lot
going on here so I'll explain a little
bit of this so
don't even need this
no we don't need all of this so let's
get rid of this
we can get rid of that I don't like the
semicolons so let's get rid of this okay
this should be what we need now it's
should just be actually we don't even
need most of this
right
yeah
I think we're doing we don't have very
different things okay
mm no obviously we can't use async/await
unless I put in
let me check back here and make sure I'm
not doing something ridiculous
okay yeah let's put back in this and
we'll take this out on another line
right now and then let's return
[Music]
let's go is
actually you know what I think we did
this exact thing in a previous project
which project wasn't it's the Resource
Center let's check it out
it's really nice to have all these
projects that we've done to just be able
to go back to and say oh we've done that
all right so it wasn't we weren't doing
it in node but it should still work the
same
all right let's do this
oops
in ports
just call this data
here we go now I don't even need to
worry about any of this stuff yet let's
get rid of it but then let's set it down
here because we will be using fetch for
our post requests but for now we can
just grab the data
okay
all right so let's just go so just to
make sure that we're actually getting
the data lets console.log and that's
good data where's my format okay
alright I'm last year if the sword but
it's worth a shot
let's go back to our terminal wherever
that is whatever okay so we're in here
let's go node well make this bigger
sorry everybody
syntax error new import unexpected
imports oh shoot maybe I can't use that
syntax in here let's do
[Music]
that's automatically is it automatically
putting in semicolons that I keep kept
taking it out of there I need to change
my settings okay let's try this now
nope turn off my module results oh shoot
it's not a module okay we got to change
this and make it a module so where's our
all right if I just double-click it in
here it's gonna be huge
Wow Wow
did everyone just see that speed I'm
really impressed I mean this is gigantic
file Wow good job Visual Studio code why
do i why is this not highlighted
properly it should be mm-hmm interesting
okay so let's do
and let's change this because I know
it's gonna be a joust and we're gonna
change need to rename it
why can I not rename this thing alright
let's just rename it from here then
babe
believe it from this great
there we go
let's to
if I'm not getting highlighting because
the files just today and it's taking
forever I don't know all right let me
check back here for a second
okay cool art Nick I see Nick explained
a lot more about what you saw by thanks
Nick
I'm definitely gonna look into more of
what you're talking about
okay
thanks I'm buried so I understood so
America was explaining a little bit more
about he's talking about us appreciate
that I'm not even sure if this is
correct syntax and will work but I'll
give it a shot if it's not if it doesn't
work out then I'll double check actually
am I thinking I can definitely double
check right now because I have a data
file that has the same thing on my other
screen that we used for project what was
it was it project I can't remember I
think project 3 whatever the Resource
Center react project was yep that's it
that is the correct syntax see I should
have just tried it and I would have
looked more intelligent I suppose all
right so let's let's do this let's go
back into here whoops
nope that wasn't it we're going to here
and yeah we really need so what happened
before I tried to
alright let's just see if this if this
actually will work this is not exactly
how it was bringing it bringing it in
now it shouldn't this is probably not
gonna work but it'd only take a second
to run it again yeah it doesn't break yo
sis yes
let's see cannot find such
I throw in a dot slash is it gonna be
that easy whoa
yes all right cool
thanks for comes all right
so now it's upset that I'm exporting it
all right
can you use can I use import in the node
let's just try it
oops
alright let's show that out
it's okay import okay I guess I can I
can't use that with note
all right so cool so Brooke saying
module exports and node not X okay cool
I don't know I just uh haha so I
Christian said you might also have some
fun coming up with the fact that all the
numbers seem to have in parts the
strings didn't notice that before but
you are correct
alright module dot exports a note not
excellent all right so let's switch it
up then
so rook is this what you're saying to do
it more like this module exports and
then what I have to do module import I
should just look up the syntax I don't
know what I'm waiting for
okay so I got the
module and board this is not letting me
no that's not all right I'm gonna have
to look this up motto exports in the
results yes file and then dot require in
the migrate okay so I do have to do
require alright so let's just jump back
here
oops
there we go all right require and then
module explores all right let's see see
what this system
okay Thank You Brooke so much this is
super helpful so rookies actually typing
in the correct syntax that I need whoop
swim in the wrong file so I don't need
all this I can just do module exports
and then that should work awesome thanks
again rook that was like super helpful
whoa yeah check it out yes okay that
part is working oh my goodness there's
so much okay so I'm trying to scroll up
so you see the top okay so here's what
we did if you remember our migrate in
the wrong way or migrate dodge a spy all
it was doing was grabbing this the data
from our JSON data which now is in a
JavaScript file such an array of objects
right and I just wanted a console log
the first object in that array and it
has done that right we can double check
this in fact is that that object so we
we have all of this right awesome
and we could potentially to take it a
step further just to test out some of
the things that we want to do let's go
with let's just see if this works so I
want to grab this Content ID and let's
try this I still want to do a console
log but first I want to do data filter
and we want to do object and we're gonna
do object-- it's what was that field
called
Content ID
Content ID equals let's go hopes up I
already copied up there we go
no it's not it huh
it's just not gonna work for me here
[Music]
I'm gonna have to do like this
Lucia
objects for that work and I've been
reviewing other people's code for way
too long instead of writing it from
scratch I've been spoiled by you all I
can't remember e syntax alright let's
just say that the goal is I should get
back the same result as I had before but
we were doing now is making sure that we
can filter this stuff out so it's basic
it should work assuming I got the syntax
right which is I don't know we'll see
this should okay sweet didn't pass
there's no one wrong
I need uh alright let's do it like this
yeah
whose
see if that works
yeah that works okay I always get
confused with filter and and how to
access what it returns but I know if I
use filter and math together it always
works okay right sorry I just saw that
now so I did not have to do it that way
but it it it proved the point of at that
point what we've done there is we were
actually able to filter out and just get
one of those now we obviously wouldn't
want to filter by Content ID right but
we would want to filter by some of those
other fields that we had talked about
before such as like post type or
whatever the equivalent is calling I
think it's called content type or
something yeah we might oh sorry
do I want to filter by date you know
different things like that I'm gonna
have to give so I'm not going to code
out the rest of this because it's about
time for me to leave and go home so I'm
not gonna code the rest but you can see
basically how it's how it's gonna work
right so this part here should not be an
issue we just follow the instructions on
the API documentation and that should
you know it should work this is
basically we've already done everything
that we want to do for the most part
it's just a matter of making it a bit
more complex doing more filtering and
then you know mutating the data somewhat
yeah so we actually didn't need to get
the data so that part for whatever crazy
reason I was attempting to use fetch to
get local day that was just gonna be in
a static file so thank you for bearing
patiently with me I really need to
change this I can't stand these
semicolons but anyway thank you for
being patiently with me as I shrubbler
through that very basic node file there
but it's it it basically works and I was
really worried about that size of that
that JSON file like what the heck is
gonna happen when I run this and you saw
it it didn't take very long so I I have
a lot more confidence now it may not
seem like it but we've come very very
far in terms of having a clear idea now
of how exactly we can transfer the data
and you know at least into WordPress
so it still remains to be seen whether
or not we will go with WordPress but
right now it's definitely the
front-runner for the CMS and I can't
really can't afford to wait too much
longer to make a decision so WordPress
might end up being just the default
because I haven't found anything else
that's that I like to use so I'd say
it's a pretty good possibility that
we're gonna be doing where we're going
with WordPress at this point and now we
know at least from the first part you
know we can be pretty confident that
this is gonna work yeah so anyway I
definitely got a lot done there's a lot
I can go tell my boss now that has been
tested and that works and he will be
very happy with that as well as you know
a lot of the other people here involved
in the project will be very relieved
because this was the big question it was
always you know I can definitely get
this done by February
assuming that we can get the data
transferred over that was always the big
if that was the caveat so now it looks
like that'll work out so I'm very
confident we can get this project
delivered on time ok cool brian says
Keystone jazz is a jazz CMS I have
looked at Keystone before I need to look
at it a little bit more in-depth and
maybe actually install it and play with
it the last time I checked it was I
don't have to double check it's been a
while it's been a while since I've used
it I'll have to check it out again I'm
sure it's been updated since the last
time I really kind of dug into it so I
will definitely check that out very soon
because we need to make a decision on
this but anyway thank you so much for
sticking around there's actually not
that many people left in the stream
it seems that databases is not a popular
topic for videos based on the amount of
people that came in lower than normal
but you know to all 16 of you who have
stuck around to the end thank you very
much I should be back tomorrow I I
haven't really checked my schedule for
tomorrow so hopefully I can stream at my
normal time thank you so much again I'm
I probably look tired right now but I am
actually really happy this is a big
relief that we figured so much of this
out and I don't think I couldn't have
could have got this far this fast
without your help so most likely I'll be
back tomorrow and until then have a
wonderful day